[Aplausos]
[Música]
el día 15 de septiembre de 2021 los
líderes de eeuu reino unido y australia
anunciaron un histórico acuerdo quizás
el primer paso para llegar a cambiar el
curso de la historia por sorpresa y sin
previo aviso los tres líderes
presentaron caucus la última alianza
militar del planeta gracias a este
acuerdo australia convertirá su armada
en una de las más poderosas de todo el
mundo gracias a la incorporación de
nuevos submarinos nucleares también se
hará con misiles tomahawk y participará
en el desarrollo de armas hipersónicas
tecnología cuántica y sistemas de
inteligencia artificial con august la
arquitectura militar en el indo-pacífico
está experimentando toda una revolución
china korea del norte y francia han
mostrado su rotundo rechazo
queridos amigos amigas el presidente de
los eeuu joe biden ha descrito las
relaciones entre los eeuu y la república
popular china como la contienda del
siglo
[Música]
xi jinping y otros autócratas piensan
que la democracia no puede competir en
el siglo 21 con las autocracias porque
lleva demasiado tiempo llegar a un
consenso que estamos en competencia con
china y otros países para ganar el siglo
21 que estamos en un gran punto de
inflexión en la historia joe biden y no
se trata sólo del presidente en
washington son muy pocos los que tienen
dudas el indo-pacífico es con mucha
diferencia la región más importante para
el futuro de los eeuu podemos hablar de
ucrania turquía rusia-venezuela o
incluso méxico pero lo cierto es que a
la hora de la verdad para los eeuu de
américa el juego el juego importante se
sitúa en esta otra región del mundo y
sabéis que es precisamente aquí donde
están concentrando casi todos sus
esfuerzos por ejemplo a principios de
marzo de 2021 y el jefe del comando
indo-pacífico el almirante philippe
davison solicitó al congreso casi 30.000
millones de dólares adicionales para
reforzar la arquitectura militar de eeuu
en la región
hablamos de nuevos sistemas de radar de
alta frecuencia centros de intercambio
de inteligencia depósitos de suministro
y un nuevo sistema de defensa
antimisiles aegis en la isla de guam y
no sólo eso las fuerzas armadas
norteamericanas también tienen intención
de construir una nueva base en
micronesia reforzar su presencia en guam
y junto con australia levantar una base
conjunta en papúa nueva guinea
pero no penséis que se trata solo de
nuevos equipos militares para nada
hablamos también de nuevas políticas por
ejemplo eeuu está animando a japón a
desarrollar armas hipersónicas y mejorar
sus fuerzas de misiles ha renovado su
acuerdo militar con filipinas y ha
acordado un paquete de 2.600 millones de
dólares en venta de armas a de este país
y en mayo anunció incluso la suspensión
de todas las restricciones que obligaban
a corea del sur a limitar el alcance y
la carga útil de sus misiles de
producción nacional la idea es que sus
socios locales consigan mejorar su
capacidad militar pero washington
también quiere reforzar sus alianzas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por eso en los últimos años ha impulsado
nuevos acuerdos militares con países
como vietnam la india o tailandia al
tiempo que también está reforzando
alianzas e instituciones como el quad o
five ice de las cuales por cierto ya os
hemos hablado aquí en visual político de
hecho se especula con que washington se
estaría planteando incluso incluir a
corea del sur en el grupo five ice que
es la alianza de inteligencia que
comparte con australia el reino unido
canadá y nueva zelanda
queremos convencer a beijing de que los
costos para lograr sus objetivos por la
fuerza militar son simplemente demasiado
altos almirante philippe davidson jefe
del comando indo-pacífico pero con todo
quizás el paso más importante con mucha
diferencia es august
[Música]
y este acuerdo militar a tres bandas
implica que australia se convertirá en
toda una potencia militar con una de las
flotas de submarinos más poderosas del
planeta también se equipara con misiles
tomahawk los cuales por cierto podrá
lanzar desde los propios submarinos y
todo ello al tiempo que comenzará a
colaborar estrechamente en el desarrollo
de nuevas capacidades militares y
tecnología punta inteligencia artificial
misiles hipersónicos tecnología cuántica
etcétera etcétera es decir que todo
apunta a que a partir de ahora es ese
electo tándem de confianza e influencia
y poder que forman eeuu y reino unido-
incluirá un tercer miembro ahora bien
porque este acuerdo puede ser tan
importante porque precisamente australia
y quizás la pregunta más importante de
todas qué implicaciones puede tener para
la región más importante del mundo
atentos
[Música]
el amigo más leal
porque australia pues principalmente
podemos destacar dos razones de peso
sobre la primera de ellas ya os hablamos
en un pasado vídeo aquí en visual
político austral y amigos el país del
sur los canguros y la ópera de sydney ha
demostrado ser históricamente el mejor
amigo de eeuu quizás no el amigo más
fuerte ni el más poderoso pero sí el más
leal de todos australia la querida
comunidad de visual política es el único
país del mundo que ha luchado con eeuu
en todas las grandes contiendas de la
potencia norteamericana en las dos
guerras mundiales en corea y vietnam en
la guerra del golfo en afganistán en
irak e incluso las operaciones contra el
estado islámico además australia es un
país rico y muy próspero que cada vez
tiene más recursos por ejemplo para
gastarlos e inseguridad
[Música]
de hecho en 2019 este país se convirtió
en ni más ni menos que en el segundo
mayor importador de armas del mundo tan
sólo por detrás de arabia saudita y por
cierto a quien pensáis que le compró el
grueso de las armas
321 exacto a la industria militar
norteamericana digamos que últimamente a
los ejecutivos de empresas como la
lógica martín la general dinamics bae
systems rey donó la norton grumman cada
vez que ven un australiano por un
pasillo se les abren los ojos de par en
par y para colmo australia está
relativamente próxima a una de las zonas
geopolíticas más importantes de todo el
planeta es decir que puestos a escoger
un nuevo socio quien mejor opción y de
hecho eso es precisamente lo que eeuu
lleva haciendo desde hace años
[Música]
en 2011 los dos países firmaron un
importante acuerdo militar que por
ejemplo permitía el despliegue de una
fuerza de combate de hasta 2.500
soldados norteamericanos en el
territorio australiano y desde entonces
la relación no ha hecho sino hacerse más
y más próxima en 2019 australia acordó
con eeuu una compra superior a las
fuerzas aéreas de muchos países 72 7 35
11 aviones de guerra electrónica 18
brawler aviones de alerta temprana y
aviones de transporte c 27j para el
files
[Música]
además recientemente ambos países
también han acordado incrementar la
presencia de aviones buques de
superficie tropas y submarinos de eeuu
en australia es decir el amigo más leal
sigue siendo el más leal de todos así
que os hago una pregunta quién mejor
candidato para compartir con él buena
parte de tu tecnología militar más
avanzada pues sabéis que dicho y hecho
bien este es el primer motivo pero
dijimos que había dos y sabéis que el
segundo tiene mucho pero que mucho que
ver con china y es que veréis durante
las últimas décadas australia fue un
país que mantuvo tan buenas relaciones
con china que según parece algún alto
funcionario chino en pekín se le debió
de ocurrir que podían tratarlo casi como
una colonia lo que con el tiempo se ha
demostrado un grandísimo error de hecho
según contó el propio primer ministro de
australia scott morrison en el wall
street journal y el gobierno chino le
exigió tajantemente que pusiera solución
a una lista de quejas si no quería
sufrir un duro castigo aranceles campaña
de descrédito contra el país amenazas
robos industriales espionaje la
interrupción del turismo es lo que se
conoce en los círculos internacionales
como la diplomacia del lobo guerrero
para evitarlo el gobierno australiano
tenía que abstenerse de pedir una
investigación internacional sobre la cob
y 19 dejar de bloquear inversiones de
empresas públicas chinas en
infraestructuras estratégicas de
australia o censurar a los medios de
comunicación para que dejaran de
publicar noticias que le molestarán al
régimen chino
casi nada básicamente lo que le
exigieron australia fue entregar su
soberanía y su libertad de expresión o
cuanto menos que la limitara y amigos la
respuesta de camberra fue un no rotundo
el caso es que las relaciones se
enfriaron tanto que el gobierno y la
sociedad australiana comenzaron a ver a
china como un peligro potencial había
que protegerse y sabéis que justo ahí
estaba el amigo norteamericano y también
el amigo británico con la mano tendida
para brindarle al país toda la
protección que necesitarán los
australianos y así así es exactamente
cómo se gestó baucus y qué queréis que
os diga viendo las regiones y la falta
de temple que hubo en china tras el
anuncio no sé no me parece una mala idea
frente a una australia tan irracional no
debería china prepararse con puño de
hierro y golpear la fuerte cuando sea
necesario enseñándole una lección
completa you see gene editor jefe del
diario estatal global times ahora bien
hay una pregunta que nos queda por
responder porque este acuerdo es tan
importante qué implicaciones tiene
exactamente como puede condicionar el
futuro de asia-pacífico pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
sonrisas y lágrimas
queridos amigos amigas podemos destacar
tres implicaciones o consecuencias
directas de este acuerdo que a su vez
podemos sintetizar en tres ideas la
nueva australia china y francia si os
parece sigamos exactamente este orden
australia es un continente insular con
una inabordable costa que he llegado el
caso puede resultar muy pero que muy
difícil de defender además en una época
en la que los buques de superficie son
cada vez más vulnerables al ataque con
misiles es algo casi universalmente
aceptado que los submarinos de alta
capacidad van a jugar un papel clave los
ejércitos del futuro
[Música]
bien hasta ahora la estrategia
predominante en australia era la
conocida como continentalismo esta es
una estrategia que centra sus esfuerzos
en defender al país de una agresión
militar directa bajo esta óptica tal y
como por ejemplo apunta del profesor
white de la universidad nacional de
australia el país no necesita grandes
submarinos nucleares sino que le basta
con submarinos convencionales más
pequeños pero más numerosos para
defender las costas además esta sería
una fuerza que por sí misma al no tener
alcance suficiente trasladaría un
mensaje alto y claro australia no está
interesada en incursiones exteriores sin
embargo queridos amigos la decisión de
apostar por los submarinos nucleares
implica un importante cambio de postura
y también de objetivos
[Música]
la gran ventaja de los submarinos
nucleares es que pueden permanecer
sumergidos más tiempo y tienen más
espacio para aportar más armas y más
provisiones también por regla general
son capaces de navegar sumergidos a
mucha más velocidad y operar a
profundidades mucho mayores todo esto
supone una doble ventaja por un lado las
incursiones son más sigilosa y por otro
pueden estar desplegados más lejos y
durante mucho más tiempo es decir su
misión puede ir mucho más allá de la
mera defensa de las costas de australia
[Música]
por ejemplo se ha calculado que los
actuales submarinos convencionales de la
clase collins de australia apenas
podrían pasar poco más de 11 días
desplegados en las aguas del mar de
china meridional mientras que los nuevos
submarinos podrían quedarse mucho pero
que mucho más tiempo es decir en caso de
ser necesarios con esta nueva flota de
submarinos nucleares los cuales además
podrían lanzar misiles tomahawk
objetivos en tierra podrían apoyar
fácilmente a las fuerzas norteamericanas
comisiones de vigilancia protección o
ataque y eso eso no es todo con este
acuerdo eeuu envía también un importante
mensaje si tienes miedo de las
represalias de china aquí estamos
nosotros no sé qué queréis que os diga
parece una buena jugada
eeuu rusia china reino unido francia y
la india australia será el séptimo una
situación que en china no ha gustado ni
un pelo y es que últimamente los líderes
chinos no pasan por su mejor momento
tienen peleas o discusiones con
prácticamente todos sus vecinos la
popularidad del país entre la comunidad
internacional se ha desplomado entre
otras cosas por acciones como la toma de
hong kong o la persecución a minorías
luego el crecimiento económico se ha
desacelerado y para colmo el riesgo de
un estallido descontrolado de la burbuja
inmobiliaria está ya sobre la mesa pero
pese a todo hasta ahora los líderes
chinos estaban acostumbrados a una
determinada forma de relacionarse con
sus vecinos si les críticas o no les
gusta lo que haces te castigan que se lo
digan sino a corea del sur a taiwán a la
propia historia o incluso a lituania
cuando china y eeuu pelean en escoria
del sur la que recibe el golpe
lituania se queja de las sanciones
comerciales de china tras el conflicto
de taiwán china sanciona económicamente
a las industrias australianas en medio
del deterioro de las relaciones sin
embargo en el caso australiano el tiro
les ha salido por la culata y eso eso es
algo que sienta un mal precedente para
sus intereses y sobre todo para su forma
de relacionarse con él del mundo
y este es precisamente el motivo por el
que el gobierno de siguen ping ha
calificado a august como una amenaza
extremadamente irresponsable e incluso
se han sucedido declaraciones de radio
pública como está armado con submarinos
nucleares la propia australia será
blanco de posibles ataques nucleares en
el futuro realmente quiere ser un
objetivo en una posible guerra nuclear o
quieres estar libre de la amenaza
nuclear víctor gago un influyente
analista geopolítico chino sin embargo
más allá de la furia los micrófonos
muchos analistas militares chinos
conscientes quizás de la enorme metedura
de pata le han querido restar
importancia
la tendencia general actual de
integración económica global es muy
diferente de la confrontación y división
entre los dos campos durante la guerra
fría el pacto eventualmente mejorará las
capacidades de combate de australia y
ayudará a los eeuu a implantar su
alcance militar pero no representaba una
amenaza inminente un pensé en analista
geopolítico chino aunque sus amigos no
es ni mucho menos un acuerdo tipo tan de
hecho esa no es propiamente la
estrategia de eeuu en la región
[Música]
y es que veréis la acumulación militar
de china es innegable durante las
últimas décadas este país ha
desarrollado y producido cientos de
misiles balísticos de largo alcance y su
marina es ya la más grande del mundo por
número de barcos sin embargo su
hegemonía en la región no es tan grande
como podríamos pensar a simple vista por
ejemplo si la armada china es la más
poderosa de toda la región pink apenas
representa en torno al 30 por ciento del
tonelaje naval los esfuerzos de países
como corea del sur japón la india taiwán
australia o vietnam entre muchos otros
hacen que la competición esté mucho pero
que mucho más reñida de lo que podríamos
pensar especialmente claro si cuentan
con el apoyo decidido de eeuu que es
precisamente lo que ha ocurrido con
australia una enorme metedura de pata de
pekín así que una sorprendente
consecuencia que podría tener august es
precisamente rebajar la tensión en la
región
[Música]
por último la tercera consecuencia
directa tiene que ver con francia un
país que se ha molestado mucho con este
acuerdo porque pues no sólo porque le
hayan dejado de lado no olvidéis que si
algo molesta de verdad son franceses
precisamente que le den calabazas bueno
eso y que le hagan de menos en la esfera
internacional sino también porque le ha
supuesto perder un negocio enorme
[Música]
august ha supuesto que australia rompe
un contrato de casi 65 mil millones de
dólares con la industria militar
francesa para construir 12 submarinos
convencionales tipo barracuda y además
lo ha hecho por sorpresa algo que el
propio ministro de relaciones exteriores
de francia calificó como toda una
puñalada en la espalda
para muchos londres y washington han
aprovechado el momento para saldar
cuentas unos por el trato sufrido
durante el break sí y otros por el tinte
antinorteamericano que los últimos años
ha tenido la política exterior de
francia en cualquier caso sea como sea
lo que viene a demostrar esta jugada es
europa cada vez pinta menos
queridos amigos amigas estas son las
claves y las implicaciones de august el
acuerdo militar que refuerza no sólo a
eeuu y el reino unido en el lindo
pacífico sino que convertirá de facto
australia en toda una gran potencia eso
sí tendrán que esperar porque los
submarinos no estarán disponibles hasta
finales de la próxima década claro que
una nueva jugada de china puede terminar
confirmando noticias como esta australia
considerará arrendar o comprar
submarinos existentes a eeuu o reino
unido pero llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti qué te parece la operación
autobús como valores esta estrategia de
eeuu de empoderar a sus socios en el
lindo pacífico como crees que responde a
la china déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y ya lo sabes si este
diputado sentó interesante no olvides
ayudarnos dándole a like y
suscribiéndote a visual político si es
que aún no lo has hecho una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]